pour l'instant sur le terrain en Ukraine
la Russie poursuit c'est bombardements
de mort et 4 blessés notamment à Carson
selon le gouverneur de l'aublaste
l'armée ukrainienne elle revendique des
avancées dans le sud et dit contenir
l'offensive des troupes russes dans
l'Est ou des combats particulièrement
difficiles se poursuivent volodimeersch
qui l'admet les progrès de sa
contre-offensive sont plus lents que
souhaité on en parle aujourd'hui avec
notre invité Paul Valley historien
politologue cherchera associés au centre
de sécurité politique de Genève merci
d'être avec nous sur France 24 les
Ukrainiens effectivement admettent avoir
des difficultés sur la ligne de front
les Russes se sont bien préparés à cette
contre-offensive
oui on peut le voir manifestement et le
reportage que vous diffusiez un petit
peu plus tôt qui suit les progressions
de cette 68e brigade
ukrainienne était particulièrement
parlant
on le voit les sons des militaires
Ukrainiens qui appartiennent à une unité
d'infanterie légère qui qui témoigne je
crois avec beaucoup de grandeur sur les
difficultés qu'une unité comme la leur
peut avoir à progresser en terrain
découvert contre des des positions
préparées voilà vous faisiez référence
donc au reportage de nous envoyer
spéciaux Gwendoline de Bono et Amar
Alami à l'ami Daoui pardon qu'on pourra
revisionner sur notre antenne à 14h30
heure de Paris davantage d'avions livré
à l'Ukraine ça pourrait faire la
différence
alors il y a beaucoup de commentateurs
justement qui relèvent le fait que les
les difficultés de progression que les
Ukrainiens rencontrent sur des attaques
qui en plus de cela sont portées sur
plusieurs fronts sont des attaques
exploratoires qui recherchent les points
faibles sur les sur les lignes russes et
il est vrai que la situation
qui rencontre pourrait être légèrement
modifié s'il disposaient justement d'un
appui aérien un petit peu plus
conséquent qui est particulièrement
important dans une posture offensive et
pendant ce temps l'OTAN achevé
aujourd'hui le plus important exercice
de manœuvres aérienne de son histoire
elle a réuni 10 000 personnes quelques
250 aéronef militaires de 25 pays
membres aux pays partenaires de
l'Alliance atlantique donc d'ailleurs la
Suède qui est candidate à l'OTAN on le
sait c'est un message clair envoyé à
Moscou
il y a tout à fait un potentiel du moins
pour la pour la défense aérienne de
l'OTAN et de ses partenaires et de ses
proches proches alliés qui a été
démontré maintes fois alors ça
certainement au niveau disons pour
essayer de contrer toutes volonté
russe d'éventuellement étendre le
conflit ailleurs ça le message a été
clairement envoyé mais bien sûr du côté
ukrainien évidemment
se pose le problème de pouvoir justement
poursuivre cette offensive avec les
moyens adéquats et surtout de pouvoir
obtenir des résultats exploitables merci
beaucoup Paul Valley pour votre
éclairage aujourd'hui sur France 24